combats semblent halte est
pour malte et déjà peine master gee
maintenant les filles on va faire un
petit blind test donc un ya une équipe
quelle équipe des pussycat dolls contre
le raid roselyne dolls vous êtes le
reste du monde voilà je veux entendre
l'interprète s'est traduit sa jante en
parle elle est l'interprète comment tu
t'appelles hélène salué l'aide un noctua
explique s'il te plaît et la haine bien
qu'elle arrive à se rabattre sur l'année
tu as peur tu as quel âge est bon ok
master gee le disco
oui voilà
donc pas encore pris le principe gagner
c'est un truc que je comprends pas on
continue martin j
dans son pamphlet du muscadet mais on
avait dit qu'on allait laisser gagner le
mans gagné ta tête on continue waouh
ouais
hop
les aides aux deux là ont fait de deux
là c'est un peu gagné en finesse on est
passé par mes parents du master gee
non
la mort
mais pas du tout nouveau sur la voie à
face à chela bien donc pour le vent ça
fait quatre points pour le reste du
monde et un seul point pour les pussycat
dolls un bris stade highbury ça allait
encore difficile en europe
oh
sylvester bravo voilà et elle remonte
tout pas une chose facile
j'ai la reprise mais celle ci à
carcassonne et en continu match perdu
ce matin
bravo 3 juillet au fort 3ème chrono et
la jouer
jean talon
ça lui attendu en régie en régie ne pose
donc un replay et on demande à ripper en
régime stable
serge sont là on a tous envie de baiser
mais en vrai c'est qui catherine barma
de djamel à catherine c'est pas
jean-paul c'est des pussycat c'est
évident en vain mais bien sûr catherine
ruelle one et aux ronds continue michael
j
à
c'est un jeu
je vous souhaite
c'est normal mais pauvre qu'elle trouve
pas j'ai fait ce poste sont pas comptés
le point faut leur donner à laver car le
poids oui le deport divise de phoques
des choses mais c'est pas possible ça va
c'est pas vraiment une chance quand même
bon continuer ainsi dit
mais avant je l'avais dit avant d'avoir
magnéto quand les gens répondent pas en
face on va dire que c'est l'été pour le
point que c'est ridicule ça vient trop
bon continuer ça le cvu 6 one you can't
stop
oui
à s'y coller on a beau mais fais pas
cette série dont je regardais de jessica
catherine me parler de jessica dans
l'oreillette
ne perdons pas ne sont froids continuant
cette émission envers et contre tout
master gee
alors maintenant est-ce que la
traductrice peut bien traduire s'il vous
plaît et mon gamin ben on finit le par
éclipser la fin du par équipes
les pussycat des risques faune reste du
monde c'est fini donc maintenant c'est
chacun pour sa gueule il faut leur
expliquer sinon c'est vrai qu'on est
certes chacun pour sa gueule
chacun pour sa gueule au jeu c'est
compliqué de mon team no more thing
normand team n'a plus fort hassle ok non
non tu ne m'en fais pas du tout
attention mesdames messieurs le bon qu
massage
d'accord
hélas
l'enjeu
championne bravo tu dois aller le serbe
n'a pas sifflé dans le public ça n'a pas
soufflé dans le public thierry bravo
quel oeil le coin pour kimberley
mesdames messieurs voilà très clairement
oui absolument
on continue tétouan des capotes bastille
il est brouillé
non
je suis ok ok c'est un méga banques aux
yeux c'est méga banques aux saillies
mégabanques negab en cours bravo bravo
c'est bien la série des mega brands qu
on va voir qui va le prouver
et
k
à l'issue du choc blind test c'est donc
les pussycat dolls sont écrasés
gagnon
deux adolescents
à
non
un homme
m
vanté comme art
à
m
voilà the rainbow et sinan al balah
khatami